Motor Trend writes the 2024 Ram 1500
electric vehicle is going to get 500
Miles uh to the charge or whatever 200
kilowatt hours provide a promise 500
miles of range and the 800 volt
architecture will speed up the fast
charging
yeah I don't I don't think it's gonna
work another put some weight in it put
some yeah so so people need to
understand this too because you know
Luke knows this we have Teslas you put
weight in those things those batteries
go down quick yeah fill the back of that
with a couple round bales of hay and now
do it in in February yeah especially
when it's cold which has a direct effect
on the batteries
they're not thinking money it's all
Biden money it's all investment into
foreign globalist corporations that of
course are going to be giving you a
product that doesn't work half as good
that is meant to of course deny you the
ability to move that's essentially what
they're doing here
electric trucks man is a crazy concept
but I I'm willing to bet Tesla will do
it better to be honest
yeah they're moving away from didn't
they create like a semi-truck uh Tesla
yeah
but they had another big one that's
going to be automated but also the
Automation and the self-driving is also
going to have a huge vast effect on on
Humanity as well fast charging is bad
for the battery yeah yeah it's really
bad for the battery you get warnings
Tesla's only let you charge by default
up to 80 unless you manually override
and if you're doing standard charging
which is like 10 10 of the speed then
you can go up to 90 but so uh what is it
like what is it what does it add look
like 10 miles per hour or something a
standard Charter I'm not sure the exact
uh I think it's 40. yeah I think because
we've got I've got a Tesla plug and I
think it it gives you 40 miles of range
every hour
so you use that car for one day for
errands and you've got to plug it in for
several hours you go to the supercharger
it'll be done in 20 minutes but it
damages the battery and only it warns
you to only up to 80 percent now imagine
you're in a truck and imagine you're in
a Ram 1500 what how much weight do you
think 1500 normally would would be
Towing oh gosh that thing isn't no more
than four tons I can't imagine four tons
yeah wow I don't think 1500 yeah I don't
think it could but I mean that but I
mean like regularly I mean people in the
chat probably know like what's the
what's the what's the amount of money
probably two tons it depends on the
hardware underneath that we can't even
mention on this YouTube channel
the hardware the hardware underneath the
truck that we can't say on this YouTube
channel what the the get it get a
transmission yes
but no no of course of course but my
question is just like if somebody buys a
Ram 1500 they're not they're not going
to be hauling commercially I mean it's
it's going to be for what like
semi-personal semi-professional yeah
this says here approximately 990 to 2
000 pounds right that's it wow yeah
nothing oh wow I didn't think it was
going to be that that's a 2014 Dodge Ram
okay well that's old it could probably
do way better these days so if you're
getting the electric one you know
they're expecting to to pull that much
if you think you're getting 500 miles of
range on that battery no and then don't
don't expect to do any like weekend work
jobs yeah because you got to stop that
thing plug it in for five hours and
don't go up any Hills how long does it
charge don't do in Winter yeah like if
you charge your battery and you just let
it sit how long does it stay charged
that's a good question on an electric
car I don't know if you if you Tesla
owners if you plug in your Tesla and
it's fully charged and you unplug it and
you just let it sit does it last for a
day two days five days a week I filled
up my gas tank like a year ago and I
haven't moved my car and it's still got
like I hope you well
too and your car battery goes bad as
well yeah the car is totally I think
it's a funk it's just 10 10 to 15 uh per
day depending if you have Sentry mode on
so you lose about 10 to 15 per day and
it's connected to the internet it's got
a sell signal that doesn't get that much
battery at all so uh how would we make a
nuclear power truck how would we do that
that's what I love about Back to the
Future remember he comes back doc comes
back at the end and he's got Mr fission
in the back of the in the back of the of
the of the uh the DeLorean right and
he's putting in all the the food scraps
why why are we not there what if we made
like a nuclear powered steam train you
know well I mean they just put water in
and it just goes the Navy has All
nuclear-powered Ships where nuclear is
not legal for for for commercial or
private use but the military uses it all
all the aircraft carriers submarines are
all nuclear powered why can't if you
want to go on Carnival cruise from here
to Jamaica why can't you take a
nuclear-powered cruise ship okay and
you're like well it's dangerous well you
let the poor 18 year old farm boy from
Iowa get on a nuclear power Germany goes
around the world so I don't know why
they don't all have nuclear power you
wouldn't need that much nuclear material
you know you know they would shovel the
coal make a steam steam engine work yeah
just put you know a couple of nuclear
rods in there and it's good for a really
long time imagine if it's just
remarkably dangerous the size of those
those tankers that bring all of our crap
from China right those things that are
the size of five football fields and
they've got 40 000 can imagine if they
were nuclear powered how much Greener
for the earth to not burn hundreds of
thousands of gallons of diesel but
they're not allowed to be nuclear
powered even in but they go in
international waters what if they made
like nuclear Auto ferries that stopped
before they get to territorial Waters
and then switched they should for some
reason or right now only only military
is allowed to have nuclear powered
usually if you have a little fancy yacht
you should have a bit small nuclear
engine I should have a nuclear reactor
in my backyard you should have one it's
like Fallout You'll Play The Fallout
games that everybody had their cars were
nuclear so in the game they explode
which makes no sense for nuclear power
but no
but people think like Nuke means bombs
so you know exactly it's the exact same
technology also they're little small
except they just build a big wall around
it so the explosions is contained white
power Works
what's the end result of this people
talk about how Tesla cars can be remote
controlled and all that stuff it's like
oh you buy the electric vehicle they're
not gonna let you charge and I'm like
they can just shut your gas station down
like if they can stop you from charging
your car they can just shut down the gas
station I mean if they don't want you
driving you're not driving yeah if the
power goes out of the gas station the
pumps don't work right exactly so people
are like in Californians that don't
charge your electric car and it's like
and well I think the biggest difference
and this is where I agree with you 100
um
for for for good the fossil fuel
industry is still in private hands if
you need gas you're not dependent upon
now your government can shut it down
true but the government doesn't provide
you with gas the government doesn't
produce it they don't manufacture it
they don't refine it it's in the hands
of the private sector the government for
good or for ill I would think for ill
the government does provide you
absolutely the government does provide
your power and so if What charges your
vehicle is gas and it's free or it's
electricity and it's government then
you're in the hands of the government
100 and that is a scary scary Prospect
they're like well I'll just put solar
panels around my house but that you know
the solar does not generate enough
electricity I'm gonna build a sale car
yeah just well they work as well as wind
turbines I'm gonna I'm gonna build a
Flintstone car and then feed all of you
guys uh but but now also another layer
to understand here with smart meters and
and smart grids and smart cities they'll
be able to calculate what you used your
electricity for since everything is
connected to Wi-Fi everything's
connected to the internet and just like
they start denying drones access to
particular territory they could do the
same thing with electric vehicles that
of course have cameras inside of cars
watch your every move and of course
could control and database you on such a
level where you could literally be
brought to a police station if you
commit a a thought crime inside of your
Tesla the Tesla will automatically
snitch on you to the central controllers
the central controllers will literally
drive you to the gulag you don't have
enough credit yeah you have no social
credit you didn't do enough Good Deeds
no you use too much carbon too much
carbon the end game here is also a
social credit carbon score that of
course the world economic Forum has been
talking about they just released an
article talking about how great was it
for people to be locked down during the
last two and a half years and how that
gives us hope to lock people down for
new social carbon credit score that
they're going to be implementing and it
gives them the possibility to do this as
they were celebrating the previous
lockdowns looking for future lockdowns
that they want to put on you and they
can only put it put them on you if you
of course acquiesce and and comply with
this utter nonsense that they have
already put us through within the last
few well that's why a lot of the greens
keep talking about climate change as a
public health emergency because as soon
as you declare as soon as you compare it
to covid then you can use the same
Protocols of covet and the greens have
wanted to do heck the greens have wanted
to make meat illegal for 40 years right
they want to make the greens are so
envious I wrote an article about this a
couple months a couple of months ago
about covet Envy The Greens look at the
the coveted people and like how did you
guys do this in in in a couple of months
we've tried for 40 years to get people
to not go to church but under covet it
was like oh sorry churches are close but
you could go to the liquor store you
could go to McDonald's
just just think about the kind of person
that would try to forcefully take away
your steak Yeah like have you ever had a
good tenderloin
amazing it's beyond meat is just as good
as Bill Gates we also did that freaky 60
Minutes interview where he talked about
how it was just as good with Anderson
Cooper just as good and guess who owns
all like the beyond meat factory freak
Show world or who buys up all the
farmland and says you can't produce cows
anymore and has man bazangas out there
in the general public and it's clearly a
very unhealthy individual then Elon Musk
post a pregnant man meme exactly I made
a t-shirt out of it and it's one of our
best sellers and it's just absolutely
it's true I went to the Frederick County
Fair this past weekend
and uh I love the county fairs are
amazing um the Frederick one's really
big because Frederick's like I think 300
000 people are some massive City and uh
they're chickens you get to go in and
there's animals all over and there were
bunnies and the bantams are always just
so funny and they were chickens and the
chickens none of them looked anywhere
near as cool as our chickens for real
like I looked at the brahmas I was like
they got nothing on Siri but for but um
I just think about that how it is not
difficult to have chickens right
even if you want to live sustainably you
get chickens all you have to do is
protect them they just eat they walk
around they eat grass they eat bugs they
eat then there's berries and those other
stuff they just eat all day non-stop you
don't gotta do anything you just fence
them off and make sure nothing kills
them and then the best part is you can
eat their babies like well you can eat
the babies before they're babies you
don't want to eat baby chicks and then
you can eat them when it's time to eat
them why take that away and make us eat
crickets when you can literally just
have the chickens eat the Crickets and
then you get the chicken meat and the
eggs and their feet you can eat all the
chicken parts yeah and then you can even
use chicken bones and whatever for
whatever it is you want to do I don't
know you can make a little car out of
them or something yeah the fascination
with crickets I see all the videos all
the time the images of like all the
cricket snacks all the
um we had uh one of the times I was here
with that that awesome Canadian uh uh
Kian right he's big into all the
different Cricket manufacturers and
cricket and I hope Ian's uh um uh kian's
watching Kian Bexley I follow him on
Twitter have you but he was big into all
the companies that make cricket food
have you have you ever looked at the
sodium levels of fake meat
I was probably through the roof lethal
like it's it's crazy I was looking at I
think I can't remember which fake meat
company it was but the sodium it was
like one burger patty was like 73 of
your daily sodium intake because it
tastes like crap yeah now look I don't
mind some of I don't mind veggie burgers
like a black bean burger can be very
good oh they're delicious quinoa Burger
I've had those are fine I love you know
and it's like it's its own thing you get
you get like a quinoa black bean with
like peas or whatever and then you can
put like onions it's good when it's
meant to be good but sometimes you want
hard protein you want just to get some
protein maybe you're trying to get all
ripped like you know Hemsworth you got
to eat a lot of fish and you gotta eat a
lot of chicken and beef is okay I don't
like to eat too much beef because it's
it's rough it's tough uh chicken and
fish is really really great but they're
taking all of that away why fish get a
pond throw fish in it and then make sure
you're not eating too much of it but
they're literally like despite the fact
that is it easily possible to have
sustainable farms for yourself and a
homestead they're like no no you should
eat the bugs nothing is better for those
farmers who are watching also than a pig
because the thing eats absolutely the
pig eats the chicken have you ever have
you ever seen a pigs eat everything I
watched a pig eat a chicken bone and it
just shatters that in one bite if you
fall in if the and if you fall on a pig
truffle pigs are eating and your hand is
in the way like watch out like they're
they're not to say that they're violent
like that but if they are eating and you
put your hand there like sorry watch
your hand buddy
I'm I want to make a pig horror movie
let's do it we got a budget who wants to
make it I'm sure there's many and it'd
be like like the pigs cometh and it'll
be like a bunch of hogs break out of a
pig farm a bunch of people in New York
state that only have five rounds in
their magazine and then there's like 50
50 Hogs I'm like no no no
girl let's do it let's make a comedy
horror where it's like you find a bunch
of stuff New York and mushrooms a pig a
pig farm just north of New York City
erupts and there's like a thousand pigs
that Rampage the city no one has any
weapons so it's just like
geometry oh and they would they would
eat so well in New York City because
there are so many homeless and drug
addicts just like sleeping on the street
no the pigs would the pigs would they
get so fat they wouldn't be able to be
violent after a while it'd be funny if
like we do a parody film that's like
meant to be silly but then it turns out
to be so so good that it spawns like a
an AMC drama series that lasts like six
seasons becomes like multiple movies in
a universe and the pig cometh
he's Australian and uh Australian
Outback your husband and you want to
talk about pigs no because in the
Australia they hunt wild boar and they
would do it for fun because Australians
are all a little crazy they would do
without any any weapons they would just
use dogs and their dogs were so well
trained that they knew which ear to grab
and if they grabbed the wrong one they
would switch so I'm on the left ear I'm
the right ear and Andrew will tell you
if you just get a pig from the behind
any farmer knows this Pigs Can't turn
around you just have to grab its hind
legs and I'm like so this is a wild pig
with two dogs on its ears and you would
just grab it's like yeah you grab its
leg and you pull out your knife in you
and he says this with an Australian
accent which I'm not gonna imitate and
you pull out your knife and you just
stab at the neck and I'm like
Australians are like crazy Australians
are very weird no a legit I want to make
a pig horror movies but look that's a
really good idea the the conflict should
be that people can only have three
rounds in their magazines
and most don't even have guns because
people who live there tend not to like
in New York don't have them and so then
it like the superhero turns out to be
some like he's a big fat redneck guy
with a Maga hat and he's got like a 100
round drum and he's like I'll save you
and then he goes to the city just mowing
down and they team up with all the gang
bangers and the gang bangers and the
Maga people come together and they fight
off the the Monsanto Pig Invasion
how much money do I need to make
something like that that would be an
amazing movie you guys know it New York
doesn't have enough guns you got a
million I mean if you're really good for
six million for the with the pigs though
unless we unless we did like really
crappy CGI pigs
I just saw um a pig trap where they they
get like these big cylindrical wire like
Gates that are hanging in the air and
then the 20 pigs go in like feral pigs
and they throw all this food in there
and all these pigs come in they start
eating the food and then the wire things
just drop and hit the ground and they
encase like 40 can trap like 40 hogs at
a time because the whole thing going out
there and killing them one by one is you
can't stop the spread of the pig because
they keep breeding the ones that survive
and we have a huge feral pig problem in
this country I'm sure a lot of the
listeners who who are from that part of
the world and every time there's an AR
story like no one should have an AR-15 I
go to Texas ranches and they're like if
I don't come out here every night with
my AR from this distance from my
protection and safety the only thing
strong enough to kill those and they do
amazing they kill cows thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there